Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge ein Tag persönlicher Koch
heute an meiner Seite Nelson Müller
wirklich eine Ehre dass du hier bei mir
in der Küche stehst ich durfte schon bei
dir in der Küche stehen ist natürlich
auch alles unten verlinkt die Ehre ist
ganz meinerseits ja freue mich schon
schön hier zu sein und eine geile Küche
weiß ich gar nicht was ich sagen ja ich
bin echt mega gespannt wenn du meine
Küche gut findest dann finde ich sie
noch besser wir machen ein Frühstück und
nicht irgendein wir machen einen richtig
schönen Bagel ich war die besten Bagels
der Stadt kaufen dazu gibt es schön
Lachs ein bisschen Avocado Limette
bisschen dahin so für den Spice ich bin
ganz gespannt was Du dazu sagen willst
weil nächsten ist natürlich nicht nur
ein sehr bekannter Koch sondern hat ja
auch ein Stern das heißt es ist wirklich
in allen Ebenen eine kranke Challenge
heute ich freue mich heute für dich
Kochen zu dürfen zu Hause nimm den Platz
machst du gemütlich machen ich haue als
allererstes mal ebay jetzt in den Ofen
machen
einmal schön auf sind ja eigentlich
schon fertig gebacken wir wollen die
außen knusprig in
ganz genau
Avocados warum Prinzip der Rob großen
Schritte eine schöne sollen wir
mindestens haben weil ich habe das
Gefühl die die ich hier gerade in der
Hand aber ist direkt schon mal wirklich
wunderschön cremig und grün falls es
nicht kennt man kann das ja immer so
schön testen wenn man hier oben wo die
an der Pflanze hängen einmal so ein
bisschen drückt und das gibt ein
bisschen nach ist nicht mehr ganz hart
dann sind die perfekt sind schon zu
weich ist oder man es eindrücken kann
sind sie drüber wir schneiden einmal auf
wir wollen ja eigentlich im Prinzip ja
quasi das Ganze zu einem Brei
verarbeiten zum Mesh Avocados ihr merkt
vielleicht auch wieder Prinzip der
robusten Schritte keine zu abgefahrenen
Rezepte für heute weil ich will Nelson
auf jeden Fall nicht enttäuschen einfach
hier eine Schüssel das Pfeffer eine Idee
dahin das ist quasi Limetten Salz und
ein wenig Limettensaft frisch noch dazu
das ist ein bisschen mühsam einfach den
Muskelkraft zeigen wir haben eine
wunderschöne Konsistenz noch so ein paar
kleine Stücke sind drin ich probiere das
ganze mal
die Frische von der Limette kommt
wirklich sehr sehr gefährlich bisschen
Salz können wir noch gebrauchen und so
von diesem Chili Geschmack geht auch
noch ein bisschen was und dann ist
unsere Avocadocreme auch schon fertig
ist es wirklich so unglaublich easy was
wir jetzt ausgewählt haben ich finde z.B
ein Spiegelei was wir darauf haben ist
so einfach dass es auch schnell nicht
perfekt sein kann
auch nur darum so ein Toast dran zu
bekommen die Dinger warm zu machen
Avocadocreme steht und Olivenöl drauf
wir lassen die Pflanze heiß werden weil
wir wollen wirklich knusprig die Belgien
sind aufgetaucht
und super schön knusprig ansonsten haben
wir noch eine weitere Schicht Frischkäse
einfach schön geräucherten Lachs los
geht's
an den Rändern schön knusprig wird und
Bläschen wird streichen wir jetzt unsere
Bagels von oben mit Avocadocreme und von
unten mit Frischkäse ich sag mal so ne
einen Tag persönlicher Kopf die Aufgabe
an den Koch ist such dir was Schönes aus
ja genau ich will mir keine weiteren
Gedanken machen und mit diesem Frühstück
landest du wirklich im siebten Himmel so
eine halbe Avocado auf einem Säge Alter
dann muss man sich halt auch die Frage
stellen was ist mehr benefit nein oder
eine Avocado og Scan wir gehen mit Lachs
dran wegen den so richtig schön
überlappend Prise Salz aus der besten
Salz Box EU westblock Shop einmal ab
kann man nur so sagen das Video schaut
ist da vielleicht schon was
so wollen wir es haben guck mal von
unten wunderschön frittiert oben Eiweiß
komplett gesetzt Eigelb bisschen runny
und fertig ist der für mich perfekte
frühstücksbagel Avocado Lachs Spiegelei
und ein schöner körniger Bagel Ruf mir
Nelson und hoffen wir dass sie ihm
schmeckt oh nächsten Zeit fürs Frühstück
ich hoffe du hast Hunger mitgebracht wir
haben hier den Smash Abo ordentlich
wieder schlafen gehen oder der Bäume
ausreißen das ist auf jeden Fall so
yummy food finde ich also das ist etwas
was man gerne mag aber so ja auch nicht
unbedingt mit wo kriegt also klein im
frühstücksladen vielleicht ne aber bist
auch gut zu wissen genau
essen darf man in Ruhe sein das heißt Du
probierst Pokerface ganz ganz in Ruhe
aufessen und dann kommen wir erst zur
Bewertung der springende Punkt 0 bis 10
musst du das Ganze gleich bewerten habe
Hinterkopf wir lassen es uns schmecken
und sehen uns gleich wieder nur bis zehn
okay die Teller sind leer gefegt das
heißt schon mal was Gutes ich hoffe es
hat dir auch geschmeckt was sagst du zu
dem Frühstück die Kombination aus Eigelb
Avocado verlängert ja den Geschmack auf
der Zunge nee das ist natürlich schon
sehr schön ist es ja so auch dieser
typische Satz damit es rutscht ne damit
es besser rutscht also schon fand war
dass der Bagel warm gemacht war alles
okay so eine Flüssigkeit und ist eben
nicht diese schwere die ja kein optisch
eigentlich vermuten lässt wenn man denkt
ja so oh mein Gott es ist hier tot durch
Kohlenhydrate das heißt genau das Gefühl
hat man nicht ganz kleiner Kritikpunkt
dieser Säure Gehalt bei der Avocado und
wenn ich einen Ticken zu hoch okay aber
ansonsten total lecker geil wenn man
sowas bekommt ich liebe sowas ich bin eh
so ein spiegelei-fan wir fahren die die
Spiegeleier so von Warstein perfekt egal
einfach konstruktive Kritik studiert
vielen Dank für die Kritik musste das
ganze aber noch in der Note fassen und
zwar von 0 bis 10 verschwinden möchte
natürlich dass da noch ein bisschen Luft
nach oben ist das natürlich hier in der
neuen geben ich finde damit kann man
schon wirklich sehr sehr gut leben weil
das ist das war halt einfach perfekt bis
auf diesen ganz kleinen Punkt wo ich
sagen würde Säuregehalt ein bisschen zu
viel ich glaube da hast du einfach zu
viel jetzt hast du Zitrone rein gemacht
hätte ich glaube da hast du warst du mal
ganz kurz gestern Abend an der Bar
irgendwie
[Gelächter]
so nice vielen Dank für die Bewertung so
kann ich anfangen darauf baue ich auf
hast du schon mal Smash Burger gegessen
ich habe noch nie ein Smash Burger
gegessen aber das ändern wir jetzt ich
mache dir ein Smash Burger der gesessen
hat der sich gewaschen hat sag mal
verdammt und hier ist alles was wir für
einen guten Smash Burger brauchen nicht
für einen guten für den besten Smash
Burger wir machen okay Oma onion Burgers
habt ihr vielleicht mal auf tiktok
gesehen habe ich da gezeigt auch hier
auf Youtube Shorts folgendes passiert
wir wollten und relativ Markus Entrecote
so dass wir vielleicht bei 20%
Fettanteil rauskommen perfekt für geile
Burger dann schneiden wir mit einer
Mandoline Zwiebeln und smashion die in
das Patty rein okay wollten wir als
allererstes mal das Fleisch einmal
halbieren wir brauchen pro Kügelchen
dass wir smashion 80 Gramm jetzt
schneide ich unser Entrecote in
wolfgerechte Stücke Aufsatz für den ich
mich entschieden habe ist nicht der
feinste aber auch nicht der grobste wir
wollen so Mittelding weil ich habe in
der Vergangenheit gemerkt dass die
Bindung fehlt wenn man selbst wollt
schmeißen wir den Wolf an und füttern
ihn so machen wir das jetzt mit dem
gesamten autorit und fertig gewollt
schaut sie euch an wir haben perfekte 80
Gramm Bällchen aus unserem frisch
geworfen und Trikot gemacht ich selbst
kann nicht erwarten den gleich zu essen
so geil no joke ich glaube das wird
richtig brutal vor allem auch okay das
ist einfach diesen Burger habe ich zum
ersten Mal bei Burger Chirurg dem
vermeintlich besten Burgerladen in LA
gegessen und so sei mein Gesicht damals
aus wir stellen unsere Mandoline auf die
feinste Stufe geben eine Zwiebel rein
und schneiden die damit auch dünn ihr
seht das da unten wie die rausfällt ich
sage euch eins das ist so zart das ist
karamellisiert und so sieht das ganze
fertig gehobelt aus no joke sind
wirklich so transparent schon fast so
weiter geht's mit unseren Toppings ich
meine der Käse liegt da ihr werdet mich
nicht ändern können ich benutze jedes
Mal und immer wieder aufs Neue diesen
billigen Sandwich Käse hier schneide ich
noch ein paar Gurken mit so dieses
klassische Cheeseburger Feeling hat
machen wir uns eigentlich Soße ich
brauche Zwiebel und Knoblauchpulver
Ketchup und Mayo eine kippt hier hinein
erstmal Ketchup das Mario mal leicht
verrühren ein Hauch von Gurken Wasser
aus
Knoblauchpulver etwas Zwiebelpulver
jetzt
ein bisschen von der Soße mit dem
verbotenen Namen dazu
Soße okay wir verrühren das ganze und
erhalten die perfekte noch ein bisschen
dicker haben
wir drücken ordentlich auf die Taste mit
Fett deshalb lassen wir erstmal ein
bisschen Butter aus auf unserer
planscher damit wir unseren jetzt gleich
die perfekte goldene Farbe verpassen
können so soll das Ganze aussehen wenn
es fertig ist wunderschöne Farbe dran
die bleiben trotzdem unfassbar weich das
wollen wir auch sein weil gleich
verschmilzt alles in der Hand zu diesem
perfekten Genuss der als Match Burger
ist wirklich hübsch vier perfekt
angetastete Burger waren die Arbeit da
müssen holen
[Musik]
darf ich nicht
ja wir sind jetzt hier und ich zeige dir
wie man smashbar gemacht ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass dir jemals irgendwas zeigen
kann aber es ist soweit ich fühle mich
leider ein bisschen ungebildet gerade an
dieser Stelle Entrecote
so eine kleine Haube Zwiebeln obendrauf
Backpapier und Menschen
[Musik]
es hat eine schöne Farbe hat von unten
eine schöne Farbe also jetzt hast du
hier noch ein Medium gab Punkt
und top auf unseren
Cheeseburger Charakter
[Musik]
Pokerface nicht vergessen
aber Max wird komplett auf diesen Käse
immer ich habe immer Stress mit meinen
Mitarbeitern weil die das als ja noch
nicht edel empfinden oder nicht
standesgemäß aber ich will auch auf den
wie haben sie dir geschmeckt ja ich bin
natürlich wir machen natürlich selber
Burger bei uns im Restaurant und da bin
ich natürlich auch ein bisschen verwöhnt
den Bürgern natürlich schon so eine so
eine Sache und dieser Smash Burger ist
natürlich auf der einen Seite geil weil
er ja einfach unfassbar viel Oberfläche
hat die verkosten kann sozusagen und wie
diese Aromen haben das macht natürlich
unfassbar Spaß auf der anderen Seite
können wir natürlich keinen Garpunkt
herstellen weil er so dünn ist dadurch
ist natürlich die Gefahr dass er einfach
nicht mehr ganz so saftig ist wie er
eigentlich sein sollte
deshalb muss ich leider sagen dass
dieser Burger einfach so geil war
trotzdem von mir und nicht nur trotzdem
sondern wirklich eine ehrliche 10 von 10
Punkten bekommt zehn von zehn ich sag
euch ehrlich das ist krank dann hätte
ich niemals gerechnet dass Nelson mir
heute eine 10 gibt aber ich habe gesehen
was die Burger mit dir gemacht haben und
du hast nicht einen sondern zwei
gegessen
habe ich alles was man wissen muss ich
hatte zwei Leute weiter geht's mit dem
nächsten Gericht wir machen Risotto mit
Spargel und Austernpilzen ja ein
bisschen vorstellen
kommen wir zum Abend essen ich sag euch
ehrlich der Burger Part hat gerade mein
Herz erwärmen etwas zeigen zu können
einfach geil Auto wenn ihr das Video
jetzt gerade noch sieht dann tut mir
einen Gefallen und guck nach dem Video
bei Nelson auf dem Channel vorbei wäre
ohne Spaß so ein korrekter Typ so ein
netter Mann und kochen kann er sowieso
es ist auch jetzt gerade in diesem
Moment ein Video online gegangen bei ihm
wo er mir das perfekte Schnitzel zeigt
und ich sage euch so viel es lohnt sich
anzuschauen ist unten verlinkt weiter
geht's mit dem Abend das wir machen
Risotto mit grünem Spargel und Pult
mushrooms ich bin sehr gespannt darauf
das ist so ein bisschen ne Eigenkreation
paar Sachen zusammengeworfen ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob auch alles gut zusammen
passt aber dafür ist ja Nelson da uns
das zu sagen ich habe den grünen Spargel
den ich wirklich sehr großzügig unten
abschneide denn wir wollen die
Abschnitte benutzen um unsere Brühe auch
mit Spargel Aromen auch automatisieren
ja das würde ich auch gerade sagen
nehmen wir zack reiner Brühe drauf und
einmal schön aufkocht den restlichen
Spargel werde ich gleich einmal schön
Angrillen auf der planschaft aber das
hat noch ein bisschen Zeit erstmal nehme
ich mir hier Pilze und Zopf für die in
eine ofenfeste Form es schmeckt richtig
lecker wenn man es dann auch richtig
wird ich habe hier einmal Kreuzkümmel
den gebe ich drüber Paprika
Cayennepfeffer zwei Knoblauchzehen und
Sojasauce
jetzt nehmen wir uns das ganze geben den
ordentlichen Schluck Olivenöl drüber und
sorgen dafür dass sich die Gewürze schön
verteilt einmal schön durchkneten so
sieht das ganze fertig aus wenn es
fertig gesalzen ist und so geben wir es
jetzt in den Backofen bei 180 Grad bis
die Feuchtigkeit raus ist und nur noch
so dieser umami Geschmack übrig bleibt
nehmen wir ein wenig Olivenöl in unseren
Topf ist folgen zwei Schalotten fein
gewürfelt die schwitzen wir an 200 g
Risotto Reis einmal dazu gleiten lassen
und auch mit anschwitzen wir schwitzen
den Reis an dadurch wird das schön
glasig und es öffnen sich die Poren
weshalb ihn auch jetzt direkt einmal
Salzen der nimmt das nämlich jetzt
richtig gut auf und gehört und ihr seht
es wir können direkt ablöschen mit
Weißwein
ihr seht hier eine hohe Hitze aber noch
keine Farbe genauso wollen wir es haben
ich brauche die magische Hand das
Kameramann und schütte dieses
übertrieben heiße Spargelwasser einfach
ohne Trichter hier hinein und sieht
jetzt schon die Stärke tritt aus gehen
aber mit ein bisschen Bein dran Alkohol
ist verkauft die Flüssigkeit jedenfalls
und jetzt gebe ich Brühe dazu mit
Spargel aromatisiert ihr habt ja gesehen
200 Gramm Reis 400 ml Brühe Öl auf die
Panzer das folgt der Spargel in Stücken
vom Stamm und Spitzen Festnetz einmal
den Risotto
[Musik]
leichter Spargel Geschmack sehr geil
jetzt fügen wir ehrenlos viel Butter
hinzu
Salz an den Spargel und Parmesan der
Bisse ist geil es wird nur noch eine
Komponente die Pilze fertig sind unsere
Pult Marshmallows die Spargelspitzen
sind gegrillt heller sind vorgelegt
Leute
Gang wir nehmen unser Risotto die müssen
das einmal schön an und fertig ist der
letzte Gang gucken wir was nächsten dazu
sagt schön wie es ist so traurig ist es
auch der letzte Gang das Abendessen es
war richtig cool
aber heute auf jeden Fall war richtig
geil dass du da warst so viel Zeit schon
mal gesagt da sind wir auch jünger
wir haben hier einen Spargelrisotto ich
bin gespannt wie gut das geworden ist da
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen zu haben wir
Austernpilze ein bisschen spicy
angemacht aus dem Ofen und gegrillte
Spargelspitzen das heißt im Risotto ist
auch Spargel ganz genau viel mit offenen
Karten ich habe eine Brühe quasi mit den
Abschnitten vom Spargel aufgekocht okay
immer Nachhaltigkeit aus und vor allem
ist es ist ja schön schlotzig es ist
wieder soweit wir essen in Ruhe auf und
dann kommt zur Bewertung ich bin am Ende
aber ich habe nur einen Burger gegessen
du hattest zwei ich habe zwei Burger
gegessen ich habe einen Bagel gegessen
ich habe fast genauso viel wie du vom
Risotto gegessen also ich habe auf jeden
Fall mehr gegessen als du
ah wie war das wie war das besorte war
sehr lecker es war auf dem Punkt gekocht
ja das ist schon echt italienisches
Handwerk das beherrschst du ja danke
schön deine italienische Großmutter
könnt
es ist bissfest diese Austernpilze sind
total geil spicy man braucht wenn ich
kein Fleisch total lecker der Spargel
auch super lecker hätte ruhig noch mehr
drauf sein können aber der ist so ganz
viel in der Küche
was sagst du zur Kombination Spargel
Austernpilz ich war mir selbst nicht
sicher aber das ist ein Klassiker
wirklich ein Klassiker ja Spargel
Austernpilze das ist äh ich habe was
ganz verrückt geworden
[Gelächter]
9,5 ich also ich habe wirklich nicht
mehr so guten Bewertung gerechnet heute
also durch die Bank bin ich super happy
mit dem super gestartet Burger
hat mir auch einfach Spaß gemacht und
das Risotto
erreichen danke dass du da warst richtig
richtig geil guckt unbedingt bei mir
vorbei wie gesagt erster Link in der
Beschreibung und wir sehen uns
hoffentlich noch ein zwei Mal vielleicht
bist ja auch noch auf dem Kanal zu Gast
macht's gut wie macht man bei euch
genauso okay ciao